well with a new year means new
resolutions and Findlay Subaru of Las
Vegas the sponsors of today's segment is
ready to set some exciting goals for
2023. take a look
[Music]
well it's a new year which means new
goals but the same love for Subaru of
Las Vegas we are here with our friend
Burton Hughes happy New Year happy New
Year so great to see you and as we head
into 2023 let's jump right into it we're
all talking about resolutions do you
yourself have some resolutions for the
brand and the community well you know we
love to do things in the community and
you know it's always my wish my prayer
that that we were able to do more and so
being able to reach out and just find
new ways to connect with our community
and and our customers and and share the
love you know that's what it's all about
hey you guys are so involved in the
community always doing different events
and giving back and is that going to
carry over into the new year and kind of
align with your your love platform here
uh absolutely we just finished our
annual share the love event it was the
15th year that we did it and four great
National Charities are going to benefit
ASPCA make a wish Meals on Wheels and
the national park Foundation two great
Hometown Charities Red Rock search and
rescue and the just one project we can't
wait to give those checks out in the
spring they're going to be a large
checks I tell you what but you know
we're going to continue that and on a
monthly basis we do great stuff a new
one that we just started is with the
Lost Las Vegas desert dogs the brand new
lacrosse team here in town and we're
doing teacher of the week so we're going
into the schools and we're celebrating
Educators that are doing something great
with their kids and and recognizing
their service giving them some funds to
to minister to their classroom and their
kids and and bring them to the the game
and celebrate them well I love that and
you guys just continue to work with new
partners new people teachers everything
is so important in the community so
thank you for all that you do and we
couldn't stop by here though without
talking about the cars let's get up
let's walk and talk because you were
just saying you have more cars on your
lot than in a long time and what makes a
Subaru perfect for say a family or
someone looking for a car in year Well
you need a car that's going to do a lot
of different things and of course Subaru
is well known for their symmetrical
all-wheel drive which means you can take
a Subaru of places that other cars can't
go and you know in other words if you
want to go up to Red Rock you want to go
to uh Lee Canyon by the way at Lee
Canyon we actually have Subaru specific
parking because we have a partnership
with Lee Canyon as a national company
and so you know those those are great
places to go with your all-wheel drive
Subaru I had no idea that is so exciting
and even more of a reason to get up
there it kind of feels like a quick
escape from Vegas and you can do it
safely in a Subaru anything else as we
head into the new year that you just
want people to know well I I have to
really kind of restate what you said
earlier we finally have new cars for for
people to come and take home now so even
though you may want to order it online
and wait for it we actually have
vehicles uh in stock ready for immediate
delivery
well thank you to Findlay Subaru of Las
Vegas for sponsoring this segment you
can give them a call at your number on
the screen
702-495-2100 they have a special offer
giving 3.9 financing for well-qualified
buyers for up to 48 months on select
2022 and 2023 models we'll be right back